Google Cloud updates since every
organization is on its own unique Cloud
Journey we are developing new ways for
customers to consume and pay for Google
cloud services from removing barriers to
entry to aligning cost to consumption
we're providing more contract and
product flexibility head to the blog to
check it out now in GA document AI
workbench is ready for production use
through apis and the Google Cloud
console because every business has
documents and as the number and variety
of those docs increases ml Solutions
will need to adapt in order to handle
the new expanded set of use cases so
check out the blog to hear what users
are saying and to try it for yourself
and also in GA confidential gke nodes
they help increase the security of your
gke clusters by using Hardware to ensure
that your data is encrypted in memory
getting started is easy as any gke
workload can run confidentially with
zero code changes required get more on
all story at the links below and thanks
for watching